In spring, when
the cherry blossoms in Kyoto were in full bloom, my
heart was deeply depressed in contrast to the appearance of the cherry-blossom
viewers.
ana
[music]
n
dong
[music]
poop
welcome
[music]
n
eh
me
Mr. Aoi
, what's wrong
?  It's early, isn't it?
That cleaning is over.
Do you have any other work
to do? Well, I don't have anything in particular
.
I don't wear gloves to check the feeling that I don't have now, but
this is my style,
so I
'll hold it and take a look at it.
It is
said that from here onwards, the pottery moon will arrive at the end.The
soil is hard
, and it is characterized by being shaped like a clay oak on a hill
.
This person's name is Kiyotaka Yazu, commonly known as Holmes. It's
been two weeks since I started working at Gura, and he occasionally holds
antique art study sessions.
Mr. Aoko Shirako is the owner of the tall house, and Mr. Holmes, his grandson,
is a hunter
.  Mr. Holmes, have
you gotten used to the store
yet?
It's always a highlight, but
em no
welcome no welcome
I want to ask for an appraisal.
So I'm really interested in Iwa-chan.
But this is a fake.
It doesn't have that texture at all. The
real thing
feels lighter than it looks.
I'm sure it's a fake born in love Kiseto 5 start I know what a young guy like you can understand
Osaka You
brought this char after knowing it was a fake
Rock
You are Osaka  I'm sure you live in
Kyoto, so why did you bother to bring a tea bowl to an antique shop in Kyoto?
It looks like you've been asked to do the
job.Is the word "bath" involved in counterfeit trade familiar to you?
You were aiming for this store, but when you found out that there was a
young appraiser with a cram school in Kyoto's Teramachi Sanjo,
you thought of deceiving him
.
I'm so inexperienced that I'm deceived by such a clumsy sentence
Piccolo-
related things go this way
Hahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahaha you really should wrap it up in Aoi's specs
oh hoi specs it's a spec
Husband
seasoned for boiled eggs  All I have is salt, but I
don't have any more
.  After that,
I always get annoyed all day,
but when I saw Aoi-san with seasoned salt, I kind of lost my gas,
oh, but I was surprised.
I can't forgive that malice, it
's a blasphemy against people who love art.
no i hate counterfeit  Just by being here, my guts are twisted, and
I'm basically black-hearted. Yoshiko
had the feeling that the instrument was black home Kotobuki-san, but wow,
that's not
the case when I first came to this store.
It's really hard to talk to
you. Oh,
come on. Look
at Holmes. Please stop calling
me Toda.
Well, it's in good condition, and it's pretty expensive. Well, Taikan Yokoyama
is pretty expensive. Yes, it's very beautiful and it's in good condition.
But what the hell is that?
Oh, oh,
did
you like it
like this?
Is it because you know a lot like Sherlock Holmes?
Yes, you are a student at Amakuchi High School and originally from the Kanto region. It's been
about half a year since you moved to Kyoto
.  That child doesn't
belong to me Why has it been about half a year since we moved in
?  I don't think that the sailor's
wife has something to appraise here.
Yes,
but you need the money,
so you took it without permission.
I'm sorry for what I'm doing.
Holmes is a nickname.My family
name is Hayagami and Kiyotaka.My
house is called Holmes because it has a head and a shell.
Taka-chan is amazing, and from this spring he will become a brother's graduate student
.
It's a wonderful brother,
I'm going to be negative.I thought
it might be Komizu right now.In terms of power, this person is Mr. Holmes, so your name
is interesting.Well, Obesa, it's a
wonderful name.
I used to be a wife dam, but now I'm in a place relatively close to Shimogamo Shrine
.  That's right,
but if it's just an appraisal, can you show it?
If it's something you brought, it might be good
.  Yo,
can you drink it?
If you have sugar and milk,
then let's add cafe au lait. It's
delicious
.
Is it always like that? No, I don't always say what I'm thinking.
It
seems that
this barrel is in good condition first of
all.If I buy it, it will be around 2 million
yen.
It's not
Anu
[Music] I was
surprised Hakuin I've
seen pictures of young children, but it's okay
This is the first time I've seen this baby party Is
it amazing?
I can't put a price on it
Blueness Who does this hanging scroll belong to
[music]?
Aoi-san doesn't seem to be the type of child who would want to take things from the family without permission and try to sell them
.
What is the reason why Mr. Aoi needs money so much that he took out his grandfather's belongings
? It's the
Shinkansen
fare.
At that time, I thought there was
nothing I could do about it.It was hard to break up in Saitama, and it wouldn't be a problem if we were separated from each
other.
I was sad, but
there are so many things I want to say We want to say that it's
terrible and can't be forgiven.
Look at this picture of
a baby octopus.  One day,
there
was an incident in which the daughter of one of Hakuin's parishioners became pregnant. When
questioned by her father, she was at a loss for an answer, and the daughter lied that she was a child of
Hakuin.  So I
forced the baby to the person who vomited it.The bad reason was that I took the baby in without a single word
of excuse.It is said that even though people were scolding me, I desperately walked around with the milk.
After telling him about it, the
father went to Hakuin and apologized profusely, but Hakuin
changed
his mind, saying that the baby had a father too,
and returning the baby, the daughter never blamed her father at all.
How do you think you felt?
[Music] You might
have been betrayed, but you
've worked hard to raise the
baby, but you've returned the baby
.
[Music]
What do
you think?Isn't the feeling at that time reflected in this picture
?Did Aoi-san also see it on top of this?
yes
hatred  I'm ashamed of myself for saying I can't forgive you I'm really embarrassed
that I was going to spit out a grudge against such a wonderful treasure
Aoi-san,
if you don't mind, would you like to work here?
Why don't you work and earn your own transportation expenses?
[Music]
Games If you want to go back to Saitama even when the travel expenses have accumulated
, I think it's good to come in and feel refreshed
.
I'm glad I was
actually looking for someone to help me.
Did you tell me that I have a good woman?
Well then, it's said that it's a masterpiece that will never be made
again.If you ask for it, it'll probably cost 60 million.In a place
like this, this is just a story for this place.
She's pure white Aoi-san, who helps out at the
shop.I reported it over the phone,
didn't I?  But that's
fine, please don't pick up on your part-time job
.
Well, if
you cut corners like this, you should make an account
, but I learned
[music]
,
so thank you for your hard
work.
Did
n't you already know that Aoi-san is the one who
can't go to
Kyoto?
There is a boy today
[music]
this is  Na Holmes and Otaga Shiraki and
I Mashiro Aoi Nan
Hannari Case Files Set in Kyoto
c
Suite
ananan
ani
me
[music]
tan
1 case
nanea
hanana
[music]
ana
me
[music]
albania
[applause]
car
aname
Home  It seems that the person's work table is involved in an incident
.